comment
et c'est est à montréal
tu as face à la caméra comme areva
grimpé face aux actes m bon bon bon bon
bon ballon ce temps pour jeumont
peut-être se jaugent à moscou
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je ne peux pas être
parler vous ce soir parce que je suis à
new york pour des concerts on a là parce
que ça peut pas des vacances tout temps
et du coup on va enregistrer une session
et on profite de ce cadre très moche qui
est manhattan pour
oh
[Musique]
j'avais vraiment un rêve c'était de
jouer à new york
senneville à pied - incroyable mais très
très rude dans la fin a besoin de tout
est possible mais aussi que rien n'est
possible
je rêve américain j'avais vraiment envie
d être pour me dire bas j'y suis pour
faire ce que j'aime et et pour faire mon
métier alors là je mettais tout proment
et
je vais aller me reposer parce qu'après
je vais leur en soit jacques lassalle
forfait d'après ce qu'ils disaient
j'ai pas dit
allez c'est pas du tout que je suis ici
pour faire un show en fait j'ai
l'impression que là je veux juste aller
voir et aurait injecté 8 mm ce prix là
j'aimerais juste place et caen rennes a
fait une super vidéo qu'elle aimerait
montrer à brut à central park
oui je chante
en deux semaines à new york un grand
building à new york d'une grillade une
des médias la messe est dite mayonnaise
trop homogène sa salle à manger des
oignons beaucoup ouais ça préparer des
mots anglais pour ce soir je pense que
j'ai parlé aux problèmes pour cent voir
mon nom 9 % des gens qu'est ce qu'on est
français
je suis hyper vraiment tous les managers
cette vie qui a été une baby sitter cas
qui est avant tout une amie une soeur
c'est vraiment quelqu'un dont je suis
très très proches en tout cas le jeu
rouge prendre la grosse tête que genre
je sais que sylvie sera la première à me
remettre sur le droit chemin at dawn à
la poste
non
stage est une fan american way il y a
deux ans esquisses ont encaissé un steak
coincé à paris et on sait pas pourquoi
elles n'ont pas reçu leur visa et voilà
donc en fait on va on sera que quoi
socialiste
[Musique]
tu essayes un petit peu tesson pour
vérifier que ce soit gbagbo parce que
c'est pas ton piano grâce a rappelé et
il va glisser un centre de l'opus
[Musique]
oui
dans la
toi
oooh
j'aime le style hyper chanceux d'être
chanteuse en 2019 parce que en 2019
c'est dans l'air du temps d'avoir une
fin comme la mienne qui déboîte assez
facilement
rim dans les années 90 c'était plutôt
les chanteuses à voix qui étaient à la
mode et c'était vraiment les choses
plutôt l'américaine qui savait qu'il
avait des appuis sens vocalement j'ai
absolument pas de puissance vocale
en même temps je pense que c'est ce qui
a fait que jusqu'ici ça ça a plu parce
que je pense c'est ce qui fait qu on
voit la reconnaissance donc j'essaie de
pas trop dénaturer autre traitement
si on prend et réaliste
du sexe il faut pas y est
parce que
il est content pour tous les gens qui
travaillent avec moi et avec qui j'ai la
chance de travailler
c'est vraiment des gens proches et
céderont des gens avec qui je pars en
vacances avec qui enfin que j'ai besoin
de voir et qui sont devenus vraiment des
piliers de ma vie pas trop non c'est
cool ou là cette promesse et oui elle
par éclater manifestants et les hommes
peut-être un tout petit promotion
honneur
je me sens propre et trop contente
ophélie seck qui est la maquilleuse
c'est aussi une sur deux grandes soeurs
depuis
depuis quelques mois on se voit tout le
temps c'est vraiment c'est elle c'est ma
maquilleuse mais c'est aussi la
régisseure artistes donc ça veut dire
c'est vraiment ma maman ça va tourner
c'est elle qui va me réveiller le matin
de tomber sur elle avec un petit et et
parfois je me dis qu'elle ne m'attarde
un peu trop ouais jacques mandeau
minutes on y joue je suis toujours super
speed
super
[Musique]
et je vis trop pressée d'entendre mes os
ça mais c'est un peu vrai mais je pense
que je rends les gars stressé toulouse
je pense à mille trucs en même temps je
vais apparaître
focus sur un truc
alors
layton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça
tu le même temps
ah ah
le fait de pouvoir faire ma musique ici
c'est juste une manière d'accomplir
quelque chose en fait
enfin métier
et ce matin
[Musique]
de plus jeune je me souviens très bien
revenir et j'aimerais bien pouvoir faire
quelque chose là j'ai encore plus de
chance parce que je suis aussi pour
faire mon métier quoi ça ça change tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a tout mangé j'ai un petit coq
est-ce que j'ai tous les balises sont
effrités des petites toques voilà ça
arrive à tout le monde
hyper bon
à
[Musique]
le canada ça fait déjà la troisième fois
qu'on vient ici à montréal on était là
il ya un an et demi pour la première
fois soulignant toute scène gratuite
francofolies montréal et puis maintenant
c'est une salle aux normes
on pensait pas du tout qu'on arrivera à
faire une salle qui vend de tout
balancer mi-temps ici à montréal
non
il ya 1 manon et rooney qui avait pas
leurs visées à new york
et hier on a eu l'information que
reçu leur passeport et du coup elles
sont à montréal sans enjeu contre en
terme d'énergie ça va être quelque chose
parce que là d'être à new york avec
juste deux danseuses de 400 m c'était
pas évident quand le lieu rue mille
personnes et l'équipe au complet je
pense que ça va être quelque chose
on me demande souvent comment je me
prépare pour les concerts et je pense
que c'est une grosse erreur de ma part
mais je ne vous parle pas vraiment je
pense qu'à partir de mètres d'une dent
may pas brillante brillante période moi
j'ai toujours été une grosse plaie mal
et donc tout ce que j'aime pas trop
faire je le fais pas moi au beach à
l'écouté
[Rires]
sur l'étude ont montré qu on se maquille
et rue des étoiles est un monde clos ce
nas mais cette cool c'est vraiment cool
c'est votre version jeu mais je peux
mettre la mienne elle est mineure
il ya la république à montréal moi
d'être d'aller jouer ici juste
l'impression d'être d'être à la maison
dans le sens où je sens une mentalité
très proche des beiges calme en europe
et de développer avec nos attentes a dit
à l'ats
ouais franchement sa brillance
[Applaudissements]
c'était perdu en l'espace d'une semaine
de faire un petit club avec des gens
très proches avec une énergie très
intense et trois jours plus tard faire
le centre bell qui s'anime ans
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde est seul en nature et sans
cesse aller plus loin et tout le monde
ce plan-là fait
et ça les fait bouger c'est pas possible
que tout le monde sait que oui mais
personne soit sur la même longueur
d'onde mais j'ai l'impression que les
énergies des jambes à elle se mélange et
sa forme en tout et hertz tout c'était
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
il ya des chansons quand je les commence
je vois plus les têtes déjà en fait je
vois que des téléphones et j'envoie
millet et voit que des téléphones et
c'est c'est bizarre parfois je me dis je
huawei ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
en train de vivre le moment où est-ce
qu'ils sont juste occupé à regarder le
concert à travers l'écran et ça j'avoue
comme montréal bas bizarrement je
trouvais qu'ils n'étaient pas trop sur
l'ensemble du camp
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui je sais pas
ouais
c'est évident à tout ça
mais bon la démagogie
[Applaudissements]